[Music]
so first just in passing I do want to
slightly say but I think your conception
of mathematics is you did say pure
mathematics is much more about a very
particular kind of set theory approach
to probably most working mathematicians
would say I don't do that yeah but
that's not really my my question my
question is do you think it's possible
that some in some of these pluralist
mathematics these different mathematical
universe some of them will be ethically
better than others you know the the
reason I say that is I've worked with
mathematicians that I've been paid as a
mathematician most of my career and my
colleagues take a great deal of comfort
from the fact that what they the tools
say you say believe it ethically neutral
morally neutral the mass itself doesn't
propose yeah but do you think it's a
possibility
that that's wrong but mathematics might
actually have something like an ethical
responsibility to that you should choose
one mathematics over another because of
its moral that's an interesting that's
an interesting even further thought I
think it might be an interesting
proposal I think mathematicians wouldn't
care very much I mean the the experience
is that mathematicians they do their
thing and they don't care about
philosophical questions they don't care
about ethical questions they pursue
mathematics in whatever way they see fit
and that's and that's that's a good
thing now if if we wanted to restrict
mathematical practice out of ethical
considerations I think it wouldn't go
over well very well with them one might
make a philosophical case for it but I
think of what it would remain without
any practical results but it's an
interesting idea hi yes you you stop
your mathematical story with Fraenkel
set theory I would have thought I was
expecting you to come on to what I
thought was the most philosophically
devastating development of mathematics
in which of Oscars girdles even leaders
theorem right girdles incompleteness
theorem do you have any thoughts of what
the implications of that has for our
perception of reality in other domains
oh yeah so so
the question was girdle's incompleteness
theorems which basically tell us that
any any axiomatic system capable of
doing arithmetic is necessarily
incomplete won't be able to prove its
own consistency so and that has in fact
really revolutionized the way we
understand truth sort of more generally
because it has introduced to us the
notion that the set of truths will
always be larger as the set of the
things we can express in language so
that proof is always weaker than truth
itself as it were so yeah it has it has
radically changed the way we see reality
you mentioned that nowadays a lot of
mathematical ideas don't have any
correspondence in reality but for
example non Euclidean geometry many
decades after it was invented helped
Einstein figure out space-time so how do
we know they won't be other correlates
in the real world of esoteric yeah well
that's yeah thank you very much so the
point is that some some developments and
mathematics that appeared at some point
to be completely remote from our
physical reality then later on turned
out to have some physical application
that's of course not a total
impossibility in set theory but given
that we're talking about well it's it's
the realm of infinity and infinity zuv
different sizes that that most of these
well sort of unanswered questions arise
it's relatively unlikely that that will
translate back into anything that will
have physical application it's not I
don't think anybody could prove that it
is impossible but it's very very
unlikely can you give me a satisfying
answer on what is mathematics oh if I
was able to do that I'd probably have
the very very prestigious philosophy
chair already somewhere next thank you
for the thank you for the question it is
is it it is a question that has been
debated for a very very long time what
mathematics actually is
is mathematics something that happens in
our heads is it a constructive
Enterprise or our mathematicians
discovering these mathematical truths
now I said earlier if you're a realist
then you're probably more on the
discovery side of things and not so much
on the constructive side of things but
no unfortunately I cannot give you a
satisfactory answer to what mathematics
is exactly but I'm working on it when I
was thinking about belief systems I came
across lekar tofs work I don't know if
you're familiar that and as I understand
it he suggested that mathematical
theorems actually come with a defensive
belt to defend them against actually the
ways that they might be criticized which
is quite relevant to our own personal
psychology and seems relevant to your
pleurisy so the defensive belt would be
against any sort of counter argument
yeah so I think that's exactly the kind
of property about the mathematical
domain that has been exploited in
philosophy for such a long time I mean
it allegedly mathematics gives us this
perfectly secure knowledge that once
it's established we can never change
again anymore and in that sense I think
this this new pluralistic ideas that are
entering the scene are so interesting
because it it really is shaking one of
the tenets of the way we understand the
mathematical realm there's absolute
certainty yeah thanks
could you say something or explain the
concept of zero in relation to Shinya as
I understand it that that that was what
brought religion into mathematics the
concept of emptiness that came out of
India oh that's a and I don't know that
much about Indian mathematics in
relation to religion I could say
something about oneness in relation to
latinas philosophy but I'm not familiar
with Shinya
I'm afraid I think in part it's just the
very idea that as I understand the
history of mathematics which is very
amateurish that it started maybe
somewhere with the Egyptians and
counting bales of wheat or whatever it
was
and they have numbers sort of things
real things particles of things which
they added up and that the the concept
of zero as in nothing
not as a placement holder actually
arrived from Indian philosophy mmm-hmm
which may be a bit different from proton
is's oneness so it's that concept it's
in Buddhism - of emptiness the nothing
the void well yeah I mean so I mean it
is the the fact that zero as a number
was only introduced fairly late after
people started using rudimentary
mathematics as work is a very
interesting development I agree with you
and that and so it's true that many
philosophers in India and ancient Greece
thought that there was something very
peculiar about either the number zero or
the number one so I can speak more about
plutinos who thought that number one was
actually very very fundamental because
it's only if we can think oneness we can
also think plurality and in order to in
order to sort of conceptualize our
entire reality we need the concept of
floral plurality but the concept of one
is always the one that is fundamental a
lot of thought has gone into what the
actual numbers mean and 0 and 1
obviously are special cases but I can't
say more about the Indian case I'm
afraid yeah thank you
so you're mentioning about the question
that you have there on the screen on how
floral is mathematics shape our
conception comes a consolidation of
reality and yeah it's a big one and your
problem focusing on perhaps these
developments in set theory as the source
that is going to perhaps create these
changes in the way that we conceive
reality however I think that perhaps
even from the
we applied mathematics there might be
changes and that can contribute to that
to that particular question and I'm
thinking in the way in which we use
mathematical models to tackle problems
in empirical sciences which typically at
some point a lot of times end up in
being setting up a set of differential
equations
that you solve but now we are moving
perhaps or starting to move away from
that paradigm in which we construct
specific models with a very specific
functional relationships between
different variables to something in
which data it's speaking by itself and
I'm specifically thinking about like
neural networks and things like that
have you considered have you thought
your question in terms of the
contributions that may come not from the
pure mathematics but from applied
mathematics which at the end are the
ones that are in constant interaction
with the empirical science thank you so
the question is does this have any
consequences for applied mathematics
specifically for the way we use
mathematics in order to model all sorts
of things in the empirical science and
social sciences etc I think there won't
be any straightforward direct
consequences for those areas and the
reason is that so I mentioned I
mentioned this set theoretic plural
verse or multiverse and all of our
standard mathematics arithmetic algebra
etc that all remains the same so the the
pluralistic split the splitting up in
different sub universes is something
that is happening at a very very
abstract level within set theory it
doesn't affect all the theorems of well
the conventional areas of mathematics
and in that sense it also won't affect
mathematical models so I think if
anything the results are going to be
most palatable really in philosophy
where we reason about mathematics on a
much more abstract level and not by
application of mathematical models for
more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you